you are so stunning thank you these are
inray locks oh my God thank
you you you are a style icon and
everything that you produced in life and
all that it's a pleasure to be here oh
my gosh I really do this is exactly how
I feel about you and I'm not the only
one you had a street named after you I
did I did Erica Alexander
way yes I mean what in your town of
Winslow Arizona yes I'm from Arizona so
they had a whole week that was Erica
Alexander week they welcomed me home
Nava Hopi miso Mexican um everybody they
gave me a beautiful Community welcome
and my mother was there what do you like
think and feel in those surreal
moments
loved both my parents were orphans my
brother was there to be honored herself
they're going to put her face on the
side of building she was an educator
uh my father was an itinerate preacher
coic and um we lived the first 11 years
of my life in a hotel called Starlight
off of Route 66 and so when they welcome
you home and they say they're proud of
you but also to tell people there that
where you are is where it's at you can
succeed and these formative years can
shape you and I am part of Arizona and
it is a part of me I'm also a part of
Philly where I was discovered so I'm
glad to be welcomed home and I was very
honored to do it but also it was a place
to call home
finally thank you there it is
that thank
you you built a family with Living
Single I did um and you just celebrated
your 30th Anniversary yes 30
years we've been on the air for 30 years
those are my sisters and TC Carson and
John Hinton and also we vet Lee Bowser
who's the first African-American woman
to make a prime time show so she paved
the way for Shonda ryes and you know so
many wonderful creators